this morning we continue our special
series we call it kindness 101 with
steve hartman sharing stories that are
built around themes of kindness and
character we like that and the people
who have mastered those qualities we
like that too today's lesson is justice
steve and his children introduce us to a
girl who convinced her entire community
to honor a man she had never even met
good morning this is my daughter meryl
and today we are crusaders for
justice and to start us on our mission
let's toss it over to meryl's brother
emmett at the dictionary desk emmett
justice is the principle that people
receive what they deserve
like if someone robs a bank they deserve
to go to jail right it can be a negative
consequence that's what police officers
and judges do but it can also mean
getting someone the credit they deserve
and that kind of justice we can all dole
out
to see what i mean we turn now to our
library of living examples and search
for justice
so what were you here for soccer game
ten-year-old sarah haycock says she was
just walking through this park in
shoreline washington so just about a
year ago yeah when she came across
something curious it was like the
beginning of a mystery yeah a stone with
a plaque this is what i first saw it was
clearly a tribute
but to who
edwin t pratt 1930 through 1969
and i'm like wow that's really short
life i just did the quick math in my
head we were like he died at 39. did you
wonder why yeah i'm just like that's not
typical
and since there were no other markings
and no one around to ask no other clues
sarah took it upon herself to learn all
she could about the life and death of
edwin pratt
she learned he was director of the
seattle urban league worked on school
desegregation and was the first black
person to move into sarah's town
it was a bold and fatal decision
pratt was assassinated right there on
the front porch
it was just the lack of recognition he's
got to have something more than just a
plaque outside of a bathroom
about that same time across the street
from sarah's school
she noticed the district was putting up
a new early learning center
she found out it didn't have a name yet
and her wheels started turning
launched a petition drive and went all
over town explaining to anyone who would
listen why that new building should be
named after pratt thank you for helping
me honor edwin pratt
over time she assembled quite a
bandwagon would all of those here
tonight to support edwin pratt please
raise your hands
at this point the school board really
had no choice but to vote on her
recommendation all in favor say aye
aye
all opposed say nay the vote is
unanimous the motion carries
about a year after that vote the edwin
pratt early learning center opened for
business
sarah got to tour the school with some
pratt relatives who flew in to meet her
and rediscover him
we as a family have gotten to know more
about my uncle than i think we ever
would have had this not happen and we
can't ever thank you enough for that
because of sarah there will never be
another kid in shoreline who doesn't
know the name edwin pratt
and someday if she keeps this up
everyone will also know the name
sarah haycox
sarah for president
[Applause]
sarah haycox my choice for the next
justice league superhero joins us now
sarah welcome to kindness 101
thank you
when he first saw the name on the school
what did that feel like
i could picture it in my head when it
wasn't actually a thing but like just to
see it felt really good to be like yeah
like that actually happened
when a lot of people see injustices they
think oh that's not my problem what made
you think that you wanted to take this
on
i think and just as kind of everyone's
problem if you can do something why not
what message do you have for kids like
me and emmett who want to do this stuff
i would say just go for it like you
never really know what will happen
and if you don't try that's at least
one outcome that's been decided
that's great advice thank you so much
sarah really appreciate you joining us
yeah thank you bye
so next time you see someone not getting
the credit they deserve
do them justice and don't forget to stay
kind
that's my favorite part joining us now
in the studio are steve and his favorite
son that would be emmett his favorite
daughter that would be merrill emmett is
12 and meryl is eight welcome hartman
family mom andreas over there taking
pictures welcome andrea good to see you
too steve why don't you start not steve
emma why don't you start us off what
inspired you about about so i think it's
i think it's amazing that one
girl can take the initiative noticing
that someone doesn't have enough
recognition and then ending up
naming a school yeah that she's paying
attention when most kids aren't even
paying attention about that merrell
number one you look lovely i like the
blazer i love how look how merrell's
sitting it's just professional i like it
meryl and i like how you always end
every segment with staycon you should
see me in the studio every day every
time you're on i go i wait wait for that
she loves it i love i do i really love
it we all do why did you why why do you
like ending your segments with that well
i think it's just really important it's
like a responsibility like if you don't
do it you're not you you're not complete
and steve i guess we should throw a
question your way as well since you're
here if we have to
yes since you're here
we'll drive them
what's the best part of doing this with
your kids
you know kindness is something and all
the things we talk about we all need
reminders it's not something you learn
once and you're done with it and i think
it's great doing it with my kids because
although these lessons do sink in they
do need reminders they're typical kids
and the adults watching i think need
reminders too so it's good to be you
know doing this over and over because
you know it takes a while to sink in
yeah you can't just do it it's not a one
not a one-time thing right that's why i
encourage people to watch these over and
over yes yes and speaking of watching
these over and over emmitt or merrill
you can take this what does it feel like
to know that these videos these clips
are being shown in classrooms around the
country maybe even around the world
well
i feel like it's just amazing to see
that someone listens someone knows
that
you're doing something and that it makes
a difference in the world yeah but it's
quite a powerful thing you're over there
on the dictionary desk and your words
are going all around the world yeah it's
definitely nice to know that other
people are listening i feel that too you
know steve i get stopped on the street
by teachers mostly but sometimes adults
but mostly teachers who say how can i
get this in my classroom i love what you
guys are doing it's so needed in the
world you must be getting this if i'm
getting stopped i know you must be
getting no we found sort of we found
just by accident almost that tens of
thousands of teachers around the country
around the world are using the stories
we have a facebook group kindness 101
where teachers can
share lesson plans and and which stories
work to teach with which lessons so we
encourage teachers to join that group
steve i've worked with my daughter and
every time i've done things with her i
learn more about her um what have you
learned about your kids during this
process i've learned that they are much
deeper thinkers than i probably gave
them credit for originally
and that i'm learning as much from them
as they are from me i think sometimes we
think of adults as the teachers but
really you know the kids can teach us a
lot too that's really good and working
with your dad what's it like
emmett in 30 seconds or less uh in 30
seconds or less
it's nice he's made this his life's
dedication kind of to spread stories of
kindness around the world and it's
been
an honor to really help him out yeah
he's an inspiration steve emmett merrell
stay tuned thank you hartman thanks this
is cbs
stealing merrill's lines